[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here for another
clueless gamer ladies and gentlemen this
is a big one Call of Duty advanced
warfare take the phone off the hook no
one does that anymore
like that that's a stupid thing to say
I'm trying to say this is a big deal
joining me now is my gaming pal mr. Erin
Blair loser like your shirt I didn't
know you stack towels at a high-end spa
really nice thank you
where are we now we're now in 20:53 this
is advanced warfare so we're gonna see a
lot of weapons that don't actually exist
one of the most exciting things about
Call of Duty advanced warfare is the
exosuit we get to wear kind of a robot
exoskeleton there's one flaw with the
suit there's no airing it's just finally
starting to sink in that's what we
signed up that's our buddy so North
Korea has invaded South Korea
we're headed into Seoul South Korea to
fight against the North Koreans why are
we getting involved it's not our war
again why is America always have to jump
in North Korea South Korea all right
well good luck South Korea good luck to
you we're gonna build bridges in the
Midwest we're in a pod that's being shot
out of a plane or there we are we're in
that pod yeah we're worried about our
ship just got hit this is a bad plan who
thought of this plan this one this one
hit that hit it a lot hit a lot what am
i doing yeah
whoa what's button gets me out of here
what's the go back home and go to law
school but you want to go inside the
building there
oh this yeah where it's this oh my god
what I forget how to move yeah no that's
good just press forward
they just kind of step out into the
doorway and shoot it why would I step
out into the gun fire a laser from a gun
or someone making like a presentation
Cooper's got a penalty hold LT and then
press RT yeah I killed two guys can I go
home now
no walk forward oh man do you want to
now I start to hear people speaking yeah
I know North Korean can I talk to them
you know at North Korean sounds like
South Korean with a Boston accent go
over to the van double tap a yeah I'd
like to double tap that a this is a true
swarm to put the drones what do I do run
up to that truck xx I run the turn now
shoot the big trouble sword oh here
comes here coming
there was fantastic that was the
greatest feeling I've ever experienced
and I've watched two of my children be
born there's more to do yeah oh yeah
this is just the first five minutes of
the game first five minutes all right
there's the ship we're good there's the
ship brother so will irons your best
friend you gonna give him the charges
that we picked up charge the charges his
arm stuff we should leave them how do I
leave him right now I want to jump okay
Zooniverse I see on the other side what
is he talking about
oh I don't like the way he's looking at
me oh my arm that kind of get the arm
just put on ice so it is time to say
farewell to private William Robert irons
man there's the casket it's a nice one
holding X to pay respects
is there a button for I'm here because I
thought I might meet somebody but I
didn't care about the guy you know hold
X to pay respect should I do it yeah
okay here we go I'm this is a really
emotional moment for me you can also
walk around the funeral if you want look
I'm too close to this guy he's getting
great day but if I go up to the widow
who's that guy who Britt is his heart he
works it on beat farm right right is the
widow gonna recognize me deal with me is
there a button that says well I guess
you're single now this is the creepiest
thing I've ever done excuse me private
Mitchell and you're Kevin Spacey
he's plays Jonathan irons the head of a
private military firm business card
this is Camp David we're on a mission
now for Alice they have recruited us and
given us a robot arm oh I have a robot
arm now yeah oh don't run up there
there's a bad guy oh yeah there you go
you didn't tell me they were bad sorry
you said we were at Camp David I thought
those were chums
no no no the president's been taken
hostage at Camp David no matter what's
happening you touch the trees
that's the sky yeah where's the
president that milk yeah going in I just
saved the president owes you see that
knows hot we need to escape with the
president all right all right under the
Humvee run - thanks folks use for
equipment Lee oh it was a training
exercise
look this is arm sir you was too early
that arms worth more to me than this
entire facility it may fix your knives
that can give me a new hand can't they
give Kevin Spacey eyes that actually
have life on them I heard one of the
greatest actors in the world and then
they give him the eyes of a carp and
it's been in the refrigerator for three
days
what you're saying is advanced warfare
what you're not seeing is anything your
eyes are dead so we're inside the
outlets training facility yeah let's go
get my arms all right go in this room
then if I had a robot left hand let's
just say I never would have left my dorm
room in college
calm down buddy we're gonna go do a
mission in Nigeria hey Gideon the edge
called he wants his hat back so now we
got to get across the street get across
the street oh nice why are people still
going to work in a war zone you know
what they should be using Waze be using
Waze and it says major battle you don't
they will say for this city they have a
lot of mass transit oh oh
ran over my head you know what they need
a crosswalk get across the street I'm
going across the street don't even slow
down when I've been hit get across the
street
shut up go
get across the street stop saying that
I'm going no I'm not leaving this room
till I get across this street this is
the hardest thing I've done in my life
you know
how's your run again gonna cross the
street yes yes there's a bridge call of
duty advanced warfare
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you